No, brother. No, you're not listening.
You're not listen you're not listening
to your to your line of thinking. And
honestly, I don't I don't I don't think
this is going to last very long.
>> You said that you that what determines
the truth, how you know that the Quran
or particular person has never lied is
because you believe. That's what you
said. So I I'm telling you I'm saying
the same thing. I'm asking you if you
can be consistent. If I say, which I do,
I believe the Bible and I believe the
Bible never lied. Does that mean that
the Bible has never lied?
>> But like you don't you don't got nothing
to back it up from the beginning of the
Bible. First of all,
>> it looks like we just going to be moving
through these uh halfbrains,
man.
Islam.
Uh for the people who were not here in
the beginning of the stream, make sure
you make sure you guys go ahead and
check out the beginning of the stream. I
was showing the emails between uh
Libyano and how he's lying out here
about the debate discussion and running
from the what he agreed to. He's
flip-flopping. Uh one path, how you
doing?
>> Yo, what's up everyone? How you doing?
>> Pretty good, man. Pretty good.
Why should I consider Islam, bro?
>> What I want to
>> Sorry. Why? Why should Why should
Christians consider Islam?
>> Now, I can tell you that Libyano can
teach you. Yeah. Why are you running,
man? We saw it yesterday. Just go do the
code.
>> You know what? All right. I I'll give
him five minutes. Let's Let's see if he
comes. You stay right there.
>> Not Not five minutes. Do three cuz he's
watching. So, let's see if he Let's see
if he joins, man.
>> Let's see if he joins.
>> Keep ducking. You keep running.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Just hold on. I'm I'm wait. Don't
Don't go anywhere. Don't go anywhere.
Let Let's Let's wait. Let's Let's see if
Liiano comes cuz I'm live.
Let's see.
While we wait for that, let's go ahead
and uh read some super chats while we
while we wait. [laughter]
Uh, Sparkley says, "Lip Hyano
will never dodge the run allegations
just like his prophet couldn't dodge the
men of Alz." [laughter] God bless you,
Avery, for all the work you do. Tough,
why are you are you like messaging
Libyaniano to come,
>> brother? He's on he's on YouTube. Yeah,
he's on YouTube now.
>> Good. So, why don't So, why don't you
message him to come? He's been invited.
>> Brother, brother, you you have his
contact information, right?
>> All right.
>> Just make go ahead and in this comment
section, tell him to come over
>> and when you get the balls to to defend
your religion, let me know.
>> Christ, Lord,
[sighs]
Salam, how you doing?
>> I'm good.
>> Good. But why should we consider Islam?
>> Yes. Uh before I start, I just want to
say if I make any mistake that is from
the shaitan. It's not from me. Uh and
inshallah I I represent Islam well.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Um so the reason why you should
convert to Islam is because we get to
sleep with 12-year-old girls. And
honestly, it's amazing, bro. You're
missing out, bro. You have to join Islam
for this reason, bro.
All right.
Just going to go ahead and block that
account.
That may be funny to you guys. I don't I
don't find that funny cuz he wasted my
time. I I don't find that funny. It's
not It's not funny.
>> How are you, brother?
>> Ahmed, welcome.
Yeah, I used to watch your videos during
your debates with some Muslim scholars.
>> Mhm.
>> So why should I accept Islam,
>> sir?
>> Why should I accept Islam?
>> Uh because of its simples. Very simple.
>> Okay.
>> Um
for example,
Islam, if you have Islam, it's like you
have peace. You understand? You are
disconnected from this worldly
activities.
You you will have a focus that I will
die. I I will live at as any time. I
will die any time. Focus on prayer,
doing good, doing um um fasting,
charity, you know, and then if you reach
the age where you should get married,
you know, you know, definitely you need
to get married, you need to have kids,
you need to raise them properly. If I
become a if I become a Muslim and I die
a Muslim, would I go to paradise?
>> Absolutely. Allah promise whoever you
understand.
>> You sure?
>> Praise to him. Do all what he needs to
do and then leave the rest to Allah.
Allah will decide for you.
>> You sure?
>> Do whatever when do your good and and
then leave the rest to Allah. Allah will
decide for you.
>> Okay. Can I read uh some Quran verses
for you?
>> Let's listen. Let's forget about the
Bible and let's just
>> you want you want to forget about the
Quran.
>> Just use your mind. Just use it's a
common logic.
>> I know. I want to I want to I want to
read the grown up a
slow down brother. Slow down for me.
>> So
um in order for me to consider being a
Muslim I I would think that you would
encourage me to read the Quran, right?
>> Absolutely. I'm encouraging you to read
the Quran.
>> Awesome. So, I'm going to read the I'm
going to read the Quran. Good. I'm going
to read the Quran based on what you
said. You told me that if I become a
Muslim and I die a Muslim,
>> then I'm for of course, no doubt, I'm
going to be going to heaven. I'm going
to go to paradise. So,
>> that's why I said leave the rest to
Allah. Do your best and hope to Allah.
>> So, will if I do my best and hope for to
Allah, will I go to paradise as a
Muslim?
>> Absolutely. Allah will give you
paradise.
>> Okay. So, this is all right. So, I want
to read the Quran a little bit. This is
Sir Miriam. Okay. These are some
important verses. All right. This is
what it says here. Um
uh it says,
hold on just one second.
Here we go. All right. It says,
why did I do that? I got to do that.
It says now this is chapter 19 verse 68.
I'm going to read verse 68 to 73. Okay
or 72.
>> It says now by your lord we shall surely
muster them and the satans the shayans.
Then we shall parade them about gehenna
hobbling on their knees. Gehenna is is
the hellfire, right?
>> Yeah. Gehenna. Yes.
>> Okay. So he's going to he's going to
send the the Satan the Shayans and the
jin and all that to to hell and the
disbelievers. Um it says then we shall
pluck forth from every party whichever
of them was the most hardened and
disdained of the all merciful. Then we
shall know very well those most
deserving to burn there. Right? Then he
says,"Not
one of you there is,
but he shall go down to it." That for
your L that for your Lord is a thing
decreed and determined.
So Allah says here, there's not one of
you that won't go down to Jah, the
hellfire. I mean, say, and this is
something that's already decreed by
Allah. Then he says, "Then we shall
deliver those that were god-fearing,
and the evildoers we shall leave there
hobbling on their knees." So there's
going to be some god-fearers who he's
going to deliver from hell. After
putting them in hell, he's going to
deliver them from hell, the Muslims, and
he's going to leave some of the
evildoers there.
So as a Muslim,
it's guaranteed. It's a decree from
Allah that I'm still going to go to
hell. I'm still going to go to hell as a
Muslim.
I don't want to go to hell.
>> No. Okay. I know. For an example, right?
Let's say um you and your friend, you
are a Muslim. You grow up, right? And
then you you are consistent of your
praying, fasting, staying away from all
what Allah forbids. And your friends he
pray sometimes he fast sometimes he do
charity but sometimes he fall short you
know life no one is perfect you
understand you fall short then if you
die on that definitely you will not end
up in the hellfire maybe Allah will
punish you for a little then he will
take you from the hell and to the hell
>> so so so I will go to hell for I I will
still go to hell and then Allah will
pluck me out. Yeah, because no one is
perfect. Cuz no one is perfect. You see
fall short, then you die. You die upon
that without repenting. [clears throat]
>> No, I repent. I I repented, but I'm
still going to go to hell.
>> No, repent. No, you have two type of
repentance. You have the repentance that
you you take your you take yourself off
from the world.
>> I know I'm
saying I repented sincerely, take myself
from the world, I'm still going to go to
hell for a little while, right?
>> No. If you die upon certain sins.
>> No, I'm dying a Muslim. I'm dying a
Muslim. I committed sins in my life, but
I die a Muslim.
>> Be a Muslim.
>> Listen. Okay, listen. Let's say, let's
say, okay, now I'm woriing God. I'm
woriing Allah. But that doesn't mean
that, you understand. Allah know the
heart. Allah know who is pure. Allah
look the heart. Allah Allah will not
look your your your your your character,
your attribute.
is look at the heart the pure of the
heart your mind
>> but I I my problem you come here
>> my my problem is this off I don't want
to go to hell I want to be saved from
hellfire I don't want the hellfire to
touch me I can't last in any in in a in
an eternal fire
>> but but it says it says look it says
chapter chapter 19 70 and 71 then we
shall know very well those most
deserving to burn there
is not one of you except except that he
will go down to it. And that's a decree
from your Lord already. So it says that
every all of us, all of you, you're
going to go to hell at least for a
little bit. And then he says, "Then we
shall deliver those who are God-fearing
and leave those who of the evildoers."
So he's going to even the God-fearers
are going to hell.
>> No, you're misquing the verse.
>> I'm not misquing it. It's verbatim what
it says, bro. I'm looking at it right
here,
>> brother. I I I'll show you. Look.
>> Look. I'll show you that I'm not
misquing it. I'm reading I'm reading it
for what it is right on the page. Look,
>> I know you're reading from your your
your laptop or your computer or your
phone. I know, but you're misquing the
verse.
>> For me to misquote, brother, for me to
mis
>> No, I understand you.
>> Okay. Yeah. For me to misquote something
would mean that I'm like I'm not reading
it correctly, you know.
>> Yeah, I know. I understand you. I
understand what you're explaining.
That's why I break it down for you a
little bit to my own little to my to my
own little understanding.
>> Yeah. But there's there's nothing to I
mean it's very clear, you know, not one
of you there is, but he shall go down to
it. Right. That's a decree from Allah.
And then he says, we shall deliver those
that were god-fearing and the evildoers
we shall leave there. So even the
god-fearing are going to be put in hell,
man. At least for a little bit.
>> Yes. Listen, you will be a godfearing.
That doesn't mean some some people will
deviate for for for a while, but that
doesn't comply mean that they will end
up in Johannam.
>> But it just said it said there's not one
of you that won't be there.
All of us, all it says not one of you
there is except that he shall go down to
it. So everybody's going to go down to
hell.
you are misquing about maybe you haven't
you haven't read from the start or to
the end brother saying that I'm misle I
please just for like this for for for
for my sanity
>> cuz I I I pride myself on honesty and
like the only thing I do is read
>> so when you when you tell me that I'm
misquing something when I'm that that's
that's saying that I am I'm I'm not
reading it correctly I'm taking the
words away from what it is you know what
I'm saying I'm reading it verbatim I'm
quoting it directly. Do you understand?
>> Okay. Do you know what I want you to do?
>> What do you want me to do?
>> I want you to take your time, please,
>> and do and and study Islam, please.
>> I already did. That's why I know this.
That's why I know this verse.
>> Who are you?
>> Amit, Amed, you're not you're not you're
not you're not paying attention to me.
>> Go and read. You know,
>> Amed, you're not you're not paying
attention to me.
>> Go and study,
>> Amed. Did I pull up Google or did I pull
up the Quran?
example.
>> Did I pull up the Quran? You pull up or
did I or did I pull up the car?
>> Okay. Okay. You pull up the Quran. Okay.
Thank you. That's what I'm saying.
>> So, as you see, Wait, before you speak,
before you speak, just I need you to
hear me out, bro. Hear me out.
>> You're not talking to somebody
who is ignorant of Islam.
Did he leave?
Dude, you there?
>> Yeah, I'm here.
>> Okay. All right. So, you can hear me.
>> Can you hear me?
>> Yeah, I can hear you.
>> Okay. Just making sure you're still
there.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I can hear you.
>> All right.
>> You're not You're not talking to someone
who has not studied Islam. You're not
talking to someone who is rejecting
Islam out of ignorance, who has not read
your Quran, who has not read Hadith, who
has not looked at your commentary, your
taps. You're talking to someone who
rejects Islam based off the knowledge
that I have about it. And according to
this,
>> I didn't go to Google. Real quick, I'm
going to give you the mic. Just give me
a second.
>> Okay, let me Okay, let me just say a few
words. Let me
>> I will just let me land. Let me land.
Let me land. I swear to God,
>> let me land my point, Amedic.
>> I don't want to talk over you.
>> Okay. No, just Okay. No, I understand
you. I understand all your points I'm
making.
>> You do.
>> I'm not We're not I'm not arguing with
you. I just want to say something.
>> Okay.
>> I swear to God, one lie to the God I'm
serving and lie.
>> Mhm.
>> If you truly study Islam, one lie. You
will cry a whole night till day break.
>> I'm not going to lie to you. I did cry.
>> I might ask you for mercy.
>> I did. I'm telling you.
>> I I Well, I I I'll tell you this. I went
when I studied Islam there there was
actually there was actually a day man
I'm not I'm not kidding you
>> I was studying Islam right I was
studying Islam
>> and I heard a conversation
with um that that an African Muslim was
having with a Christian
um I was listening to this conversation
and this this Muslim African Muslim was
so confident and in Muhammad in the
Quran and Allah so confident, so you
know, genuine to his belief with Islam
and he just thought that it was just the
truth. He thought it was so strong. But
the Christian began breaking down to him
what Muhammad did and said and what the
Quran said. Um, and this is dur during
my studies with the Quran and I'm
looking at these verses. I'm looking at
these hadith and it's saying exactly
what it says in the context. I'm looking
at the context like, wow, that's what it
says. And the and the Muslim when he
found out what it was saying, he broke.
He started crying. Grown man started
crying on this live stream. And I was it
it hit me. It hit me that I even started
crying because the man was so sad that
he forced his wife to become Muslim. And
he felt so deceived. He felt deceived by
his people by by the imam. He felt
deceived by Allah in the Quran. and he
felt so guilty for making his wife
convert to Islam and separate from her
family. He felt so guilty. He was
sobbing on the on this uh on this in
this conversation. It made me cry and it
put it ignited a fire in me like man
Muslims really do not know the truth and
they don't know what their religion
teaches. So in my studies, I definitely
had a moment where I definitely cried
out um in sadness for the Muslims. So
that's why I'm here doing what I do.
Ahmed, you don't you you're not you're
not accepting what the Quran says. The
Quran The Quran promise you. I will I'm
going to let you say this. Hold on a
second. I'm going to let you say it.
Hold on.
>> Your Quran guarantees you hellfire. The
gospel guarantees you heaven and the
father's house. A room in the father's
house. In heaven. That's what the gospel
guarantees.
>> Accept. If you want me to accept If you
want me to accept, I will accept it. Let
me say something. Okay.
Um I grew up in Saleon.
I live among I I live among Christians.
I have a church beside my compound.
Even though at night when I'm sleeping,
they preach. But let me tell you they
have never preached about next world.
How you going to die? How you going to
be judged in the grave? How you going to
be raised? Example, how you going to
face Allah? You understand? One day in
one day in heaven, one day in heaven, do
you know how many years
in the sight of Allah is 50,000 years?
You understand?
>> What does this have to do with what
we're saying?
>> Excuse me. Excuse me. A man, what does
this have to do with what we're saying?
>> Listen, that is to preach fairness in
you the day the day you going to die.
>> I'm going to hell even if I'm a Muslim.
Why aren't you dealing with that?
>> Hold on. We're not talking about hell.
We're not talking about doing that.
>> We are, bro. You bro, I want to go to
heaven. I don't want to go to hell. If I
become a Muslim, I'm going to hell.
>> Listen, I know you go to heaven.
>> No, I'm going to hell.
>> According to the Quran, I'm going to
hell.
I accept you. Let me just say something.
You accept that the Quran teaches that
we're all going to hell. Even you.
>> Excuse me. Okay. I accept for your sake.
Let me just say something that listen to
me.
>> Don't No, don't accept for my sake. This
isn't for you to preach. This is for you
to talk about truth.
>> I accept. Okay.
>> Okay. I accept. So, as a Muslim, so
wait, hold on just a second. So you
accept that even Muslims, you die a
Muslim, you live a Muslim, you're still
according to Quran to the Quran
guaranteed to go to hell. You accept
that?
>> I accept. Let me say something.
>> Then I shouldn't then I don't want
Islam, bro. That's not for me. Why? Why
would
>> Why would Why would anybody want to join
a religion that guarantees them hell?
>> Okay. No one Okay, let no one accept to
Islam. Let me just explain something to
you.
>> So you want to leave?
>> Let me explain something to you. Let me
just explain something to you, please.
Let me explain.
>> Explain this.
>> No, explain this. Amit, if you're not
explaining this, you're going to die.
Amit, if you're if you're going to if
you're going to deflect, I'm going to
move on. Explain this or concede
completely. This isn't for you to
preach.
>> Okay, I concede. Okay, I concede. Let me
>> Then why then why are you still a
Muslim?
>> Because of Islam. Tell me exactly what I
want to hear.
>> That you're going to have
Um, no. About my life, about my death.
>> So, you want to go So, you want to go to
hell. That's what you want to hear. You
want to hear that you're going to hell.
>> That's what you want.
>> I like your name logic because of the
word logic.
>> Amen. Appreciate
>> that.
>> Appreciate you for coming. You guys hear
the brain deadness of Islam.
He accepted what the Quran said
and said that the Quran tells him
exactly what he wants to hear. The Quran
tells him he's going to hell.
Period.
You're going to hell. That's what you
want to hear. You don't want to hear
that you're going to paradise. You want
to hear that you're going to hell.
But notice what they do, guys.
He was doing that in order to just get
away from that so he can preach Islam
to my audience.
Dude, I preach Islam every day.
The audience hears Islam consistently,
right, guys? We What the only thing we
do around here, y'all?
What's the only thing we do around here?
Y'all let them know.
That's it.
We just read, man.
Trust and believe my audience when I do
Islamic topics,
they're getting Islam preached to them.
Make no mistake about it. When we talk
Islam, we we preaching Islam to them.
We read we reading Islam to them.
We read Islam to the audience here.
Trust me, they're very aware of what
Islam has to offer.
And Islam offers each and every one of
you guys listening under the sound of my
voice and to the thousands that's going
to listen later.
Islam guarantees
you hell.
There isn't one of you that will not go
down to it.
Not one. None of you will escape it.
That's what the Quran offers you.
If you want that, if that's what you
want,
I can't I can't I can't hold your hand
and grab you and drag you anywhere else.
I I can't force I can't force you into
heaven.
You want to stay in a burning house,
that's on you. Only thing I can do is
tell you that your house is on fire.
That's it. But if you don't mind being
in that burning house, you want to go up
in flames and smoke,
nothing I can do.
The diamond lawyer says, "That brother
trying to preach Islam to an original
Quran only Christian. I stuck for it.
[laughter]